[Music]
odd for me is very important in life and
I think that artists really must exist
to give their messages to the work and
the artists are people who remain
forever if people forget the name of
leaders or kings or presidents they
never forget musicians and figure the
Arctic Farah diba Pallavi was an icon of
the 1970 along with her husband the Shah
of Iran Mohammad Reza now of Farah
Pahlavi lives in exile her home in Paris
is full of artworks in the 1970s Farah
was the face of Persian culture here
with Andy Warhol she also founded
Karen's Modern Art Museum like other
culture then it was financed are just a
shark's budget there are other critics
saying that the revenue from from the
oil prices should go and other things
instead of maybe for art web or what do
you say to that in your developing in so
many areas and people who want to
criticize they all also always find
something they're proud this is for it's
a cultural heritage and material
heritage for Iran and the Iranian people
compare the price that we bought in
those days till today Iran was in
turmoil in the 1970s liberals demanded
freedom of expression Islamists pushed
for an end to what they regarded as the
westernization of their country 1979 was
the year of the Iranian Revolution
Chavez la vie and his wife Farah had to
flee not one day that I don't think
about Iran and every other because the
country like Iran with great
civilization with great wealth with
these people and when you see the
condition of Iranian people today in my
country I cannot I really suffer a lot
because of the condition of women the
freedom the way they are insulted they
were their treat
the Islamists who took power in 1979
locked away the shafts art collection a
part of the collection was meant to go
and show in Berlin in December but Iran
didn't approve sign off on the
exhibition in time and the show was
cancelled
the reason is unclear one of the rumors
is that that you could could make legal
claims one once the artworks would have
left the country this is ridiculous in
other aromas when I will help to build
this museum was for Iran and for the
Iranian people
these works belong to Iran and Iranian
people when this collection comes out in
Germany and in Italy I hope the museum
will make sure that the works will go
freely back back to Iran Farah diba
pavlova is still hopeful the work she
collected in the 1970s will make it to
Berlin and that they'll be shown in Iran
too
[Music]